Yeah,
I got to tell you that your victory speech after you beat you on,
uh,
was my all time favorite because it wasn't even just about you or about the
fight.
It wasn't about anything.
It was just you expressing yourself.
Pat,
what are you doing over there?
You right.
Checking out the sorrow.
Okay.
Tassel.
Yeah.
No,
uh,
I just think that,
um,
uh,
it was an awesome victory speech.
It was really amazing.
It was a,
you were,
you know,
you were just spilling your heart out and it was in your,
your moment to shine and in your moment to shine you,
you didn't make it about you.
I think I fight better that way,
you know,
when,
um,
you know,
it's always about me,
like throughout the training camp,
like everybody,
like my coaches and teammates,
they're always helping me and it's just,
it gets to be a bit much sometimes,
you know,
and I want to,
um,
I want to help other people.
Um,
it feels my spiritual cup more,
um,
you know,
spiritual cup.
Yeah.
Um,
I think that,
you know,
I've,
uh,
you know,
if,
if your hands close to,
to give,
you know,
you can't be open to receive kind of thing.
And,
um,
I think that,
the more that I can give to people,
the more that I can get myself,
you know,
and I think that,
um,
you know,
just like plants and animals,
the way,
you know,
if you look at nature,
everything is a symbiotic relationship,
but I think that humans can be the same way.
That's an interesting way of looking at things.
Have you always looked at things like that?
No.
Uh,
uh,
I shouldn't say,
not always,
but a,
I always was a person that,
you know,
want it to be outside.
I want us to be in nature.
I grew up in a,
like urban jungle and Milwaukee and just concrete everywhere,
you know,
no place to go outside except for,
just playing in the alleys and stuff.
But,
uh,
um,
my,
my lineage is from Lithuania where they're like very in tune with nature and
they're pagans and like slash Christian and uh,
so they really,
you know,
just,
just my whole family,
you know,
they come from living off the land and stuff like that.
And so that's always been something I wanted to do.
Um,
and I'll just put it in this situation,
you know,
just to,
try and do martial arts and trying to like,
uh,
you know,
I guess control my emotions and stuff.
Just living in this chaotic environment that I grew up in and um,
nature is where I felt the most piece at.
So that's always something that I connected with.
And then the more that I kind of,
uh,
focus on nature and animals and stuff like that,
I noticed that,
you know,
there's a,
I don't know,
I tried to live my life the same way.
Well,
it's just interesting leading up to that fight to that you are kind of like the
antidote to a lot of things that people are getting annoyed at.
Nema may all the trash talking and all the negativity and all that,
like fighting at press conferences and you just shut all that shit down with
Yolanda.
Wait,
there needs to be balanced.
Know it's like,
I mean,
I like entertainment.
Yeah.
I,
you know,
I should talk sometimes too,
you know.
But,
uh,
I,
there just has to be a balance,
you know?
And it has to be honest too,
like if you really feel this way about somebody,
like if you're really upset with this person,
yeah.
I say how you feel,
but like don't just go out of your way just to be entertaining because you think
it's going to be funny or something or you think it's just going to be like,
it's not genuine,
you know?
Yeah.
But it was just the way you handled yourself.
Like,
cause her whole thing is talking shit.
The whole thing is scaring people and did boogie woman and coming to get,
you know,
all that stuff and you were just dead faced and I think,
yeah.
Fucked her head up.
I really do.
So,
uh,
you ever see that video of like the,
what was that video with all that?
Not that one.
The one you just showed me earlier,
it was like,
is this dude like standing in front of an elephant?
And they like started charging at him and he was like calm,
you know?
And he just stood there.
Yeah.
I don't know how crazy it was.
Trample them.
Yeah.
We just watched it on elephant is coming through is like,
yeah,
I've seen that.
Just stands there in one spot.
Don't try that at home.
Yeah.
The difference then obviously,
cause you're talking about an animal.
Right.
But it just,
I think it's a good analogy to draw from like Yolanda energy.
She was very like chaotic and very in my face and very threatening.
Intimidating.
Yeah.
And like,
yeah,
don't go out of your way to stand in front of an elephant's running at you.
Like don't put yourself in that position.
But I,
I had to be there.
That's my job.
You know?
So,
um,
so when you're in those situations where he like,
you don't know what's,
do you know,
you just stay calm.
Yeah.
Well,
you didn't just stay calm,
you stayed eerily calm and you were like reciting the Lord's prayer when I asked
you that,
I was like,
whoa.
It was like,
what are you saying over there?
And you're like,
I'm reciting the Lord's prayer.
Yeah.
Uh,
the whole training camp was just crazy.
But like that week in particular,
like I was convinced that this might be my last fight.
This might be my last day on earth.
Like I was so just like ready for anything at that point,
you know?
Why were you thinking that it might be your last fight?
I don't know.
Some crazy.
I Dunno.
Just cause,
uh,
I don't know.
I think I started to think that almost like every fight is because it's,
uh,
it's tough.
Yeah.
It's tough,
but it's the best thing in the world.
Especially the,
the,
all of the,
all of the stressors that came along with this fight in particular,
right?
Especially all of those,
like [inaudible] and then we have what we've,
we've had,
uh,
in that fight we had a,
we had a few,
like kind of,
I don't want to say magical moments,
but say for instance,
we bring Mishka with us everywhere we go.
I'm dog,
our flight was delayed three hours,
four hours.
And when we landed,
we landed like a few hours after that truck drove through the park and killed
all the people in New York,
which was right by our,
which if we would've been there on time,
we would've feel assigned the pollsters and then been outside of the park
walking Misha.
So I mean,
just little things like,
like that,
like we would have been outside maybe at that spot and had been witnessed to
that.
Right.
Thank you.
Would have heard it or something and that would affected me,
you know,
and um,
eh,
the Antifa March.
Yeah.
And there is just all this stuff about,
you know,
like people are going to be protesting and stuff like that and they even like
the day of the fight and I just get a lot of anxiety over that stuff.
I get anxiety over like big crowds of people and it's like,
you know,
just feel like crazy.
Yeah.
Um,
you know,
and it's,
uh,
yeah.
I just,
I wasn't even just thinking about the fight when you,
Ana,
it was more than that,
you know,
it was like what,
uh,
what all her energy re represented to me like all my past,
like,
um,
just negative people that,
you know,
uh,
want to want to strike fear into your heart,
you know?
And um,
I wasn't gonna let that happen even though I was scared,
but you know,
I just,
uh,
I wasn't going to stop doing what I was doing just because of that.
Well you were eagerly focused like one time she stuck her fist in your face and
touch your face.
You didn't even move.
Yeah.
Cause I know she needed a reaction from me.
You know,
it's just like,
um,
it's just like with anybody,
you know,
so you don't give energy to something negative.
You don't feed the fire,
you know?
Yeah.
That's gotta be a mind fuck for her though.
Right.
[inaudible] used to people reacting to her and headbutting bet,
you know,
going head to head with her trying to show her and you just stay calm.
Yeah.
Cause I mean,
you know,
it's,
it's uh,
either you really,
Eh,
I mean it's either one or two things.
Either you really disliked me enough to like,
you know,
put your hands on me outside of the competition or his fight,
or it's a character or are you just doing this for show?
Right.
You know,
it's either one of the two and I just don't think she's really a bad person.
I just think that,
you know,
she's put in this position and maybe she,
that's what she felt like she had to do.
Why I wrote something about the Volk on owes the Mirror Daniel Cormier fight the
other day that what owes Tamir was trying to do and what me was trying to do.
It's like they're trying to sow seeds of doubt that you're trying to,
there's a real issue with someone that's about to fight where you're about to
compete and it's this crazy nerve wracking thing.
And the unknown is always there.
You don't know what's going to happen,
right.
So someone can convince you,
I'm going to fuck you up.
You're like,
God damn is he gonna fuck me up.
Like you really start thinking it if you,
if it's in your head.
And that,
one of the things that Daniel said in that fight was that there's,
there's levels to this thing.
Like,
you think you're going to come in and fuck me up with this.
He's like this,
he's not you.
You're not,
you haven't experienced this yet.
Right.
And as it's something that I,
you know,
I,
uh,
Avalara's by for you want to sell,
you know,
and I think it's great that I was putting this position to face her because I
had to get better and are like,
I had to get up to that level in order to face her.
And I had to do a lot of research and,
uh,
work on my mental stability.
I mean,
she kept saying I was mentally unstable,
like,
and those,
you know,
phone calls and stuff,
the conference calls beforehand and I was like,
okay,
you were mentally unstable.
What was the cause?
Rose's mentally unstable?
Yeah.
Oh,
my dad,
my dad was,
was correct.
Like in what way?
Uh,
I mean,
well,
I don't know.
To me,
I can't speak for myself,
but like,
uh,
it's just,
please do,
you know,
sorry.
You could go it.
Okay.
It's like everyone getting ready for a fight.
It's,
it's,
um,
there are some people who can be excited about the fight the entire time and
they don't give a shit about anything and they just need you to do.
I love it.
And then there's also the ones who,
who get ready for a fight and while getting ready for the fight,
it's nerve wracking.
And especially with all of the Boogie woman and all the,
you're mentally unstable.
And then in the history with her dad and her history growing up and just all of
those things coming to a head,
this was exactly what rose wanted it to be.
The scariest possible situation for her to be in New York with the end,
with the Antifa march that happened in front of the hotel the morning of we bet
we almost didn't make it to the fight.
I Dunno man.
It's like somebody asked me like,
what's different since you've been champ?
And I'm like,
really?
I'm just sitting here trying to figure out what's different.
You know,
like obviously you're sitting here talking to you like that's cool,
but I'm talk to you before.
Yeah.
I mean you talk to you now that this crazy thing happened.
Right,
right.
Um,
so yeah,
I mean things are different,
you know,
like I definitely notice more,
more people,
uh,
recognizing me.
We have a very unique look to with your shaved head.
Yeah.
I can't hide or you don't have to wear a used to go to the movies.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
And you guys are going to fight again in April.
Back in New York.
Yeah.
That'd be cool though.
Eyebrows come to Brooklyn.
This is coming to Brooklyn.
When you,
when the fight was over,
what did you,
what did you take some time off?
Like,
how did you,
did it?
Did it even sink in?
Like how do we had to go?
We had to get fuck out of their way or they go home like,
um,
like all of this.
So like the,
you know,
the,
the truck accident and like the protests and all this,
you know,
paranoid that I had,
I had to um,
hideaway,
I'm,
I'm a hermit,
so like I like to like to be,
we went home,
he went straight to the airport.
Two 30,
two 30 in the morning flight wasn't until 9:00 AM
there was gonna be a marathon.
Right?
Yeah.
The next day.
Yeah,
we heard there's going to be a marathon,
but also rose did what she did and as soon as it happened we all went,
oh fuck.
Oh.
I like,
I robbed a bank.
Like,
oh,
like
everybody be cool.
Just keep smiling.
Wow.
Yeah.
That was it.
I mean obviously I knew that was going to happen.
Um,
I actually envisioned me knocking her out with like a Burka and the third round
cause I thought she's going to be like overly aggressive after a certain point
that she would get frustrated.
That didn't happen cause it,
you know,
uh,
she thought I was throwing a jab but yeah.
Why do you think that,
I mean when you went into that fight,
she was such an overwhelming favorite.
She was thought of as being one of the pound for pound top fighters in any way
class.
And why did you think that you're going to knock her out?
Because everybody tries to take her down.
Everybody so desperate for the take down that it's like her striking,
I mean this from what I see is,
I mean I sit across from volunteering shut Chanko and like we go like back and
forth.
Like it's not a thing to me.
Like I got Pat Barry,
pat you bury in my corner.
I got Trevor Whitman and my corner and I had done taekwondo,
a striking like my whole life.
Like it's not something that I've never seen before.
Right.
You know,
and just that Dutch style,
like kickboxing,
like it's great.
It's hard.
It's very intimidating to send across from,
but you can,
you know,
it's very rhythmic on the beat.
Like it's not,
I don't know,
it's,
it's just something that it looks scary but it's not to be scared of,
you know,
that's interesting to where you're putting it because most people thought of her
as being like this very solid.
Her fundamentals are rock solid.
She's incredibly technical.
Yeah.
Vicious Jab.
You know,
but you just saw that the rhythm was predictable.
I mean we,
we knew everything she was going to do before she did it,
watching it for a long time.
Right.
You know,
like,
and she is the,
the like,
I mean she has the most dominant female.
Like these girls could not hang with her,
you know,
and she's still the best out there,
been on the radar since she'd be Carla.
Like we knew that that was the fight as soon as she'd be calling.
And it was just a matter of how are we going to get there?
Like,
what route are we going to take to get there?
And so when the fight came around a big,
a big,
this whole,
this entire training camp was mental.
It wasn't physical.
The whole training camp every day was mental mentality,
mind,
mental,
mental strength,
just mental,
mental,
the entire training camp.
And one of the keys to the fight was knowing what she's going to do before she
does it.
And I mean,
not just in the fight but in the interviews,
in the press conference,
backstage,
like we,
we,
we knew everything that was going to happen and it all happened exactly the way
we knew it was going to.
Wow.
Yeah.
We were there.
This was,
this was an excellent dissection of a person of an athlete.
Now what is the feeling like having gone through that,
having accomplished it,
having literally blown it out of the water,
right?
Yeah.
You smashed in the first round.
Crazy moment.
Yeah.
Now you got to do it again.
I know.
Yeah.
That was the tough part.
What's the,
what's the thought process?
Um,
you know,
just,
uh,
you can't make the,
what is this thing of Haley said?
I don't know.
I'm gonna mess it up,
but she can't paint the model.
It's a twice,
you know,
like,
so it can't be the same approach.
You know,
it has to be something different.
It has to be.
Um,
but you know,
at the same time,
and if any broke,
don't fix it either.
So like,
uh,
it's gotta be a combination of like,
yeah,
we're going to keep doing what we're doing,
but,
you know,
keep getting better obviously all the time.
I mean,
it sounds a little center
on cliche.
We don't prepare for one in particular person.
It's always were roses on the road to getting her black belt.
And that's what the,
that's what the mission is.
I mean,
of course,
uh,
we,
we do get into particulars based on who it is,
but that's only for a very short period of time.
The whole goal is just to make Rose A.
Black belt in every,
in grappling,
wrestling,
striking,
like just interviews,
everything.
Just,
just become a black belt,
become a master of all of it.
And that's been,
that's been the
Golson like even,
um,
another,
like he was saying the mentality of this last training camp.
It wasn't just like a,
you know,
okay,
I'm going to,
I'm in a journal,
which I do,
you know,
during all that are all like,
like we talked about just doing like a float tank or something like that.
Like those little mental exercises are great,
but also like,
um,
uh,
working on creativity.
What's up?
I was about to say,
I just,
I was just doing the number of ice baths she took.
Oh yeah.
I did a lot eyes mass.
I said,
yeah.
Oh yeah.
The last one was the worst,
the last every day.
But like every day to a point where it actually became challenging for me to get
the water colder cause I was like,
this is ridiculous.
How should you get in and within,
under now it's gotten to a point now it had been under 25 seconds.
Like the,
you know,
when you first get it right,
like it's under 20 seconds,
120 seconds and she's just stone faced.
It's just amazing.
Yeah.
The last one that I did,
like it was hurting so bad.
I was like crying.
Like I never had either the,
where I start crying and like,
cause it hurts a bit.
But anyway,
like,
yeah.
So that,
and then on a lot of benefit from that.
Yeah.
I do like,
I mean the,
yeah.
Reduction of inflammation.
Yeah.
And then just like mentally,
mentally,
and emotionally too,
right.
Um,
no,
cause it's like,
why is this so scary?
But it hurts,
you know?
Um,
but it's,
it's good.
I mean,
if you can get in the cold ice baths and nobody's in across music and scare you,
it's less scary than the cold.
But,
uh,
[inaudible]
okay.